the idea around it was that people could
join physically in a kind of disclosed
location which was meant to be secretive
and and underground although it wasn't
literally the idea is that people would
then have to come off grid as a way of
participating in the class so that it
was meant to be a a hidden secretive
kind of Fight Club kind of thing they
would have to disconnect as it were from
tracking and so that made the class even
more secretive and a bit more kind of
interesting I guess some of the things
that we talked about you know tracking
technologies cookies and you know people
cover their webcams you know for cyber
security reasons and what better way to
talk about those things if we actually
have to try and undo them as much as
possible
send them initially some very cryptic
invitation to say would you be
interested in joining an underground
class that we're going to talk about
privacy I wanted to make is a sort of as
a more the game as possible I did she
read something similar in dragnet nation
by Julia Angwin
as I'm I wonder if I could make that
work and then fortunately I did so I
sent everybody I'm a cryptic message
about well whether we were going to meet
because at that time I know that Google
was you know searching for keywords in
email so I didn't want that to come up
as you know I didn't want to fail before
it anyone even meet because the aim was
that the location would be hidden I mean
there's only other thinks is obviously
using Twitter whenever things there are
trackers but I wanted to try and keep
the location itself as the thing that we
were trying to protect the first step
was I wanted them to download the tor
browser tor literally stands for The
Onion Router right it is an
implementation of Onion Routing
and the institution I was working at the
time you couldn't download it because
because the network wouldn't let you so
has they have to go home and and you
have to download it there but today were
download the tor browser then they would
go onto my website where I had
pre-loaded and some clips I wanted them
to be looking at in in the class find
the video that was you know video one
buffer into their browser so that we
could say on band
once they arrived then they'd have to
open another tab log into Twitter
because then they'd probably go through
its security kind of procedure so the
view would have to log into Twitter so
that was all kind of setup I then wanted
them to start disconnecting and so they
would have to then close all of their
programs or tabs whatever they were
using then they would turn off their
Wi-Fi their turn off their Bluetooth if
they had it connected on the computer
and then they would kind of like it's
close the lid and put it in the back
then I wanted them to look at all their
other smart devices that they have
support that's a smartphone SmartWatch
whatever else they have and then I asked
them to go on to their location services
completely switched off location
services and then ask them to turn off
Bluetooth turn off Wi-Fi and then
finally put it into the flight mode I
wanted to do it kind of step by step so
that they kind of would see oh there's
all these different things of why is she
asking me to do that is I a reason for
that is it it's am I going to be trapped
in some way using bluetooth and my gonna
be tracked using Wi-Fi I asked them to
switch all that off before they started
traveling because I didn't want there to
be a certain drop-off point where all of
the people would just be switching off
because that then would then trigger
okay it's there I purposely chose
somewhere where I knew that you wouldn't
get a Wi-Fi handshake it was only going
to be one network they can connect it
which is the one that I created through
my mobile device through a VPN so the
idea was and they were connecting to
tour through a VPN private hotspot that
I had created for them in the first
class there was a point of failure which
was which was kind of nice because it
was a learning point so what happened
was that we were all there we had the
class and it was all we know reasonably
kind of underground as it were and then
somebody else who wasn't who did not
follow the procedure arrived late
because somebody must have measured them
this person arrived and they tweeted say
Oh
at blah blah blah has just arrived at
hashtag privacy Eugene like and I said
okay so now we are now our location is
is compromised and in people said well
how and I said it's because of the
network so essentially you have tagged
someone and saying it
have come to this location if you just
look up there where their mobile is
situation cuz if they have their
location GPS on you can find too you
know a very fine point where they are
and thus where the rest of us are so it
was a really interesting kind of point
to discuss on a technical kind of level
I would be interested in learning about
other bits of how we can unwed and I
switch off other tracking elements to
try and make it even more kind of
underground I suppose but yeah I think
I'd be interested in sort of multi sited
having other kind of advocates you'd
like to I don't know to do it do one as
well yes one of the things that we were
talking about was the lack of
transparency from companies and from
government that we don't know how how
accurate or how well these tracking
things work and how what we can do to
you know rather take back control or or
if we're happy with them using that data
then letting the music but the feedback
loops of these of the tracking
technologies are so obfuscated we might
mean we do see on a regular basis you
know personalized advertising for us and
that's probably the clearest view but
loop that we see of tracking technology
so if I went on Amazon and I was looking
at I don't know a pencil case and then
suddenly that came up on my facebook I
said okay well I know that's there
because I was looking at that earlier I
might not understand how it got from
there to there
but I can kind of see the link sort of
thing but there are lots of other things
that could be done with that data and we
know recent news revelations with
Cambridge analytic are is that we aren't
sure of what the in-between bit and what
then the end product might be we live in
a connected world and we like to be
connected we like to be connected with
other people it doesn't we don't
necessarily like to be connected with
tracking technologies I mean there are
there are great ways that you can kind
of mask things like you can mask your IP
address using a VPN for example you can
use the tor browser if you wish although
that that does bring some other issues
and mean some websites can break and not
really work very well kind of thing and
you always ask for like security kind of
questions and those sorts of things so
there are things that you can these
small things that you can do on a
regular basis like I have a VPN on my
phone a VPN on my laptop
prefer to use that where possible some
some networks do block it which is
frustrating but I mean I I know that
completely disconnecting it is not
really worthwhile for me but I have come
to a point where I'm educated enough
fortunately that I can pick and choose I
mean at some times I do use Google Maps
for from you know searching or going
somewhere don't you know you think it's
sat-nav essentially but at that point in
time I'd rather get from A to B in a in
the most efficient way possible then be
late and lost and and just because I was
I don't want be able to have that data I
mean I might be mindful about where I
start start my my journey I might
actually pull away pull off onto a
lay-by ya bit down the road I know
generally the direction I'd like to go
in but I mean I have I've come to a
point where I understand that but
there's so many people that don't I
personally believe that this is a topic
that other people should be kind of
aware of and have an opinion Arvind and
also kind of have some you know tangible
things that they can do you know well if
they want to protect themselves but the
whole idea of making it in this way is
that it's kind of like a game that you
although you know we don't have anything
anything to hide which is the debate
I've really hate a good way to try and
and see if whether it worked is if
somebody could come along and try and
hack it and see whether they they could
find out where we were so then we kind
of actually have sort of like sort of a
bad day so to speak to kind of you know
hide away from but again it's not about
it's not necessarily about hiding but
it's kind of testing the technology and
seeing whether we do truly have the
ability to kind of stop things from
happening if we don't really want it to
let's get this out of the way first if
your password is password you probably
want to close out your browser right now
and change it and you know hang your
head a little bit if there's any
variation on the word password or have
any of the numbers 1 2 3 4 in or doing
it you need to delete those passwords
maybe delete your account out of shame